all right here's what we did yesterday
the first four rounds of the all-time in
the prime draft chris you're up round
five let's get through as many as we can
who you got all right well i guess i
need at some point a pass protector here
so i'm gonna go with jonathan ogden all
right left tackle baltimore ravens need
somebody to protect patrick from home so
he can dance back there and make all
these plays i'll go with him
all right i'm going with randy moss and
i'm i'm telling you if you hadn't taken
jerry rice because i was afraid you're
going to take moss next i was i was
going to take advice i would have taken
moss anyway because even though rice is
more accomplished and i think better
because he got the most out of his
talents
and i'll take my chances with a guy
who's got more talent in his prime and
it's randy moss yeah okay all right yeah
you know what i i i should have took
them off i don't even need prime randy
moss i'll take 98 randy moss i'll take
ricky man that might have been private
anyways disgusting act yes that is a
disgusting act you know
okay that's your first receiver that was
a great game that was his last win with
the vikings 2004 playoffs go ahead all
right um i'm gonna go back to defense
here i'm gonna get ray lewis in the
middle of my defense first off but he's
playing middle linebacker for me man two
baltimore guys back to back and they
were on the same team at one point uh
but yeah drafted the same year in the
same round
you know come on the best middle
linebacker ever period that's all there
is to say about that so i'm taking him
there
i'm going deacon jones next whoa
i
he especially if
if i can
bring him in his prime with the ability
to perform the head slap but even
without the head slap deacon jones
unappreciated because stats weren't or
sacks weren't a stat or stats weren't a
sack back then i i think deacon jones
every bit as potent as reggie white and
i i'm a little surprised football his
story and you didn't take him over no i
know i i feel listen that's where i feel
bad some of these old school guys are
worthy of being picked here and i you
know of course wasn't i know of them i
know how awesome they were i've watched
a lot of nfl films videos but yeah
they're not as prevalent in my brain as
some of these other guys that you know
were playing in my lifetime um all right
that's a good one there you know what um
i'm gonna go back to wide receiver here
i am i'm gonna i got my homes i need
another threat down the field i'm gonna
go with another team i'm on terrell
owens you took moss i'm taking t.o next
that's going to be my guy
you know i i don't i don't hate that uh
and i need another offensive weapon as
well i've got barry sanders they've got
randy moss i've got to augment him them
with someone in his prime yale sayers oh
gail kansas cop
lineup lined him up in the slot didn't
have slot receivers back in that day put
gail sayers in the slot put gail sayers
in the backfield put gail sayers
anywhere give me gail sayers all right
all right i want one more all right gosh
what do i want to do here um uh i'll go
aaron donald here i'm going to make a
reggie white lt aaron donald i mean geez
your quarterback's dead brady's dead
we can't play
more
i forgot about aaron donald we talked
about him yesterday and i thought we
actually had taken him oh boy um hmm i
go a lot of different directions here
give me ronnie lot i don't have a safety
yeah i have a safety i got a guy in the
corner and i'll have a safety ronnie lot
i kind of like this i wish we could
continue to do this really because i
think my neck i want to go gronk next
take gronk a tight end that would be my
next pick i think wow yeah wow yeah i
want a good tight end he can run block a
little bit and you know of course be a a
big time threat in the past game
i i i was closing in on taking another
quarterback because i'm in hindsight
maybe i should have taken johnny united
but i'll stick with tom brady we'll be
back with more oh
okay hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports